21st appearance for brewstar graderall
3-0
he's got the most free and easy hundred
mile an hour fastball you've ever seen
yeah at 100 miles an hour averaging it's
the hardest fast ball out of the dodger
bullpen tonight as an opener and he
drops down to the hardest slider on the
team at 88 miles an hour bruce stark
coming off an outing where he tied a
career-high two innings through 25
pitches has had one day off so maybe
that'll be just the first inning maybe
four batters we'll see what dave roberts
says there's charlie blackmon to face
grouderal one out one on
this ball crushed deep right field way
back and
god
that a baby charlie blackman
two-run home run was that ever loud and
for charlie his tenth home run of the
year
kyle freeland making his 17th appearance
he's four and six three-and-oh in august
he's been throwing the ball really well
in august he's cut back on the walks and
cut down severely on giving up home runs
the run he's on right now only a half a
home run a game so that's one every
other game that is really good for him
or anybody who pitches through colorado
mookie betts
came off the disabled list and dodgers
didn't skip a beat when he was out in
this run of really good baseball and
betts launches it to center field a
little deeper hilliard still has room to
catch it on the track one of the most
respected guys in the game right there
here's the one two on albert and a good
pitch by freeland and he strikes out
pujols so he's got the first four
tonight oh he goes after that one that
was down and that curve ball is gonna be
a little harder to hit two outs nobody
on and aj [ __ ] will come up
and that is a wonderful breaking ball
freeland with his second strikeout
another one two three inning for kyle
smith batting in the eighth spot of the
order
this one's deep to left field down the
line and done
where there's a will there's a wave
and he hit it way out there
2-1 will smith with his 21st home run
trey turner over one trey grounded out
to the shortstop rogers to lead off the
dodgers first
[Applause]
brand new ball game at dodgers stadium
justin turner tried out to sam hilliard
in left center field
this in front of the mound
crone look out
chrome bailed out and hopefully diaz
didn't get hurt
cj's knee ran right into the back of the
calf and the ankle of diaz diaz will
head off under his own power
he's putting together a little bit of a
threat conor joe at first sam hilliard
at second still one out
popped him up
roger's got in the way of will smith but
smith
able to make the catch
now he's got to face charlie blackmon
blackman has hit well against the
dodgers he has a 300 average over his
career against the dodgers
ground ball right side pujol scoots over
to get it
3-1 to put out good work to work around
the two walks cj crone will
lead it off for the rockies here in the
sixth he has struck out twice tonight
this ball lifted high and deep left
field jenny you were on it that is long
gone home run cj crow and his first at
dodger stadium
and he puts the rockies in front three
to two in inning number six that ball's
blasted homer number 23
rbi 73
30th ribby in the month of august for cj
crone connor joe can't believe it kyle's
been
good in dodger stadium this year his 2-2
pitch to pujols
bounce towards short backhanded by
rogers has time with pujols running and
throws him out
another fine effort by rocky's lefty
kyle freeland rio ruiz will pinch hit
for kyle freeland freeland's knight is
done
payoff pitch
and he got him
and then he'd follow it off
hit him swung and miss and hit him in
the thigh that's what i thought okay so
he did strike him out you don't see this
very often full swing and a miss hits
your back leg
also got a little piece of will smith
that's a very good reaction for swinging
him to see getting hit by the ball now
brendan rodgers over three
there's a ground ball to turner
he'll go to first
and they're going to say that joe was
out of the baseline that'll be a double
play
they're gonna say he went too far to the
left
and took himself out of the baseline bud
black wants to have a conversation about
this
but the dodgers will take the twin kill
here here's bellinger's first played
appearance tonight
1-2 on bellinger and he got him that's a
dirty hard slider on the outside corner
so bellinger goes down now with one
outrage turner will come two two
where's that strike three for holmen i
thought it was not gonna be called a
strike
jim wolfe said yeah it was there
trey turner is out number two
justin turner go for three today fly
ball to deep center as last time
and the ground ball weakly the second
that's a great inning for daniel bart
has the catcher elias is
one for three this ball is well hit left
center field it's got a chance to get
out and it will just over the
outstretched glove of aj pollock and the
rockies lead at four to two max muncie
he's gonna get the call pitch hit for
our kuhls
3-2 got him
with a change-up
what an enormous out that was corey
seeger one for three tonight 3-2
got him on the corner it was another
change-up
two-gun in the dodger ninth aj pollock
trying to keep the game alive
did he go
yes indeed ball game over carlos estevez
after giving up the lead off hit to bets
strikes out muncie seeger and pollock
and the rockies have defeated the
dodgers 4-2
you